muy buenos días las elecciones en perú
tiene programadas de siete de la mañana
hasta las siete de la noche pero por lo
visto esto estaba un poco en
el centro de votación que nos
encontrábamos al igual que en otros
lugares del país recién se están
comenzando a instalar las mesas de
sufragio están comenzando a llegar los
miembros de mesa y también los
ciudadanos en estas jornadas se ha
establecido que los adultos mayores
mujeres embarazadas y personas con
discapacidad tengan el primer horario de
sufragio que va de siete de la mañana
hasta las nueve y posteriormente en los
granas lo irán desarrollando diversos
ciudadanos a esta hora diversos
candidatos de los 18 que compiten en
esta élite electoral estaban ofreciendo
un desayuno a los diversos medios de
comunicación es tradicional una
costumbre muy curiosa en el perú que los
candidatos en el día de las elecciones
realiza un desayuno con sus
colaboradores con la familia y estoy muy
seguido por los ciudadanos
así es francisco pero también en medio
de estas elecciones está la pandemia el
país vive el peor momento sanitario por
cuenta del virus qué medidas han
desplegado las autoridades para
garantizar la participación de los
ciudadanos
este es un dato muy importante porque
ningún miembro de mesa en estas
elecciones ha recibido la vacuna contra
el coi 19 y también está por otro lado
que solamente se han inmunizado a
500.000 peruanos por eso el gran dilema
de los ciudadanos es ir a votar pero no
contagiarse con el coronavirus por eso
el presidente de francisco sagasti a
través de un mensaje al país y pidió a
los peruanos ir a los centros de
votación y se garantiza el desarrollo se
ha establecido protocolos de
bioseguridad en el cual se norma que
cada ciudadano tendrá que acudir con una
mascarilla y además emplear un protector
facial se tendrá que llevar cada uno un
lapicero y el alcohol los centros de
votación cerrarán a las 7 de la noche a
partir de esa hora los medios locales
emitirán flashes informativos de votos
emitidos a boca de urna y a las 11 y 30
de la noche se conocerán los resultados
oficiales los primeros resultados